I only very recently got introduced to
mr. Hitchcock so pelham and I was I felt
a special affinity to his creations and
the more I learned about him realize
that he has a background in engineering
was a formally trained engineer a
background and engineering opens up
enormous number of possibilities it
gives you it's what I call a platform
mindset it is not about solving one
thing but it is about creating a network
of opportunities what we call a solution
space because you're just not after one
thing but one thing could lead to
another and there's so many spillover
possibilities that could be achieved
through engineering one of the
approaches that engineers really
capitalize on is what i call the modular
systems thinking the ability to break
down a system into its composite modules
and understand those modules at the
level of how they are linked to one
another in logic in function in time and
space and so forth and rebuilding it
back together because that exercise
enables you to isolate and understand
what the strong links are and what the
weak links are within that system Alfred
Hitchcock was I think a pioneer in
understanding and applying this sort of
thinking the deconstruction that
reconstruction part of it in his
creations and I think the best example
for that is the movie called the rear
window with the Jimmy Stewart he really
exploited the the potential of montage
technique where you break down things
into pieces and then piece them together
in different ways so that you have the
ultimate goal in this case motion
picture continuity the narrative
progression so I think this montage and
the modular systems thinking go very
well and demonstrate how mr. Hitchcock
was able to
capitalize on these foundational
principles of engineering design to
achieve something potential others
couldn't